as enterprises continue to look for new
ways to innovate unlock the power of
their data and create personalized
customer experiences integration has
become an obstacle to success
traditional approaches to integration
simply can't keep up organizations need
to increase the speed of integration
while lowering the cost to do this a
modern approach to integration is needed
by adopting an agile integration
strategy paired with IBM cloud pack for
integration you can support the scale
security and flexibility required to
power your digital transformation IBM
cloud pack for integration can be
deployed on premises or on any public or
private cloud environment by leveraging
Red Hat open shift allowing your team to
innovate and scale in a sandbox without
putting your existing infrastructure at
risk learn innovate and scale at your
own pace while continuing leverage your
existing investments IBM cloud pack for
integration leverage is the right mix of
integration capabilities to balance
traditional and modern integration
styles simplify the management of your
integration architecture and integrate
three times faster while reducing the
cost of integration by one third let's
start by logging into IBM cloud pack for
integration as you can see a single
login provides you with access to all of
the integration tools your team needs in
one unified experience in the sidebar
are all of the capabilities let's take a
quick look at each we'll start with API
lifecycle which allows you to create
secure manage share and monetize api's
across all of your cloud environments
using the built-in developer portal a
robust API strategy is a key component
to any modern integration strategy take
control of your API ecosystem and scale
integration the next capability is
application integration from the
simplest software as a solution
application to the most complex
on-premises systems your team can use a
broad range of pre-built connectors to
quickly integrate data and applications
without worrying about mismatched
sources formats or standards our
enterprise messaging capability is a
security rich messaging
solution develop through our years of
experience with IBM MQ trusted by some
of the world's most successful
enterprises simplify and facilitate the
exchange of data while ensuring that
each message is sent and received only
once no modern hybrid integration
platform is complete without event
streaming which uses Apache Kafka to
allow you to not only send messages
easily and reliably but also to react to
events in real time enabling you to
provide your customers with more
personalized experiences our high speed
data transfer is truly unique CIND share
stream and sync large data sets
virtually anywhere reliably and at
maximum speed across global IP networks
accelerate collaboration and meet the
demands of complex global teams without
compromising performance or security the
secure gateway found in IBM cloud pack
for integration provides organizations
with a single multi-channel gateway to
meet the security and integration needs
of today's digital business while being
able to access all of the integration
styles your team needs from a single
interface is great there are also some
additional benefits to this unified
experience including common logging and
an asset repository
the common logging feature found in IBM
cloud pack for integration allows you to
search and visualize log entries across
your entire integration environment you
can find logging links for every
individual instance in both the header
and instance lists these links launch
cabaña with predefined filters for each
capability
the asset repository is a centralized
hub allowing teams on IBM cloud pack for
integration to work collaboratively
sharing and reusing resources to save
time and improve efficiency while we've
briefly touched on some of the most
important features and capabilities of
IBM cloud pack for integration the value
really becomes clear when you see the
power of using some of these
capabilities together the improvements
in your team's work flow and efficiency
through IBM cloud pack for integration
combined with the benefits of an agile
integration strategy will enable your
business to support a modern agile
approach to integration and keep up with
the increasing demand for integration
thank you for watching take the next
step on your cloud journey by visiting
our website
you